hello
since my uh title slide has the word
network in it so many times
i need to start by answering the
question what is a network
so a network is a set of nodes connected
by edges we often draw it this way so
this is a
drawing of a network with five nodes one
two three four five
and six edges you know for instance
there's an edge between one and two here
um we often represent these nodes and as
a set one two three five
and edges uh represented by set of edges
so one two is the
set one two uh this is a very
simple version of the graph and uh it
doesn't give you much sense of what
we're gonna be
doing with it but we'll have the whole
talk to talk about that
before we leave this i'll also mention
that
these nodes themselves don't have to be
numbers they often can be more
complicated objects
um these edges may be directed
uh you know often with arrows uh will
indicate
the directedness so there could be an
edge not between one and five but from
one to
node five uh they should be weighted
they could have capacities
uh these can be much more complicated
and we'll see many many
uh more complicated versions in a moment
all right so uh for the first part of
the talk i'll start by
giving you some examples uh more
complicated examples that i started
uh and we'll also talk about some graph
analysis or network analysis problems
then before telling you what network x
is i'll also need to tell you a little
bit about
sort of the data structures and
algorithms that we use
to work with networks
for the second part i will focus mainly
on telling you what network
is uh going over its functionality and
features
uh i'll briefly tell you a bit of our
past and what we're currently working on
in
the future and then i'll conclude by
showing you where you can learn more and
also asking you to help get involved
with network access development
so for examples and problems uh there
are many many examples
of physical phenomena that benefit from
network analysis so
for example there's networks of highways
railroads power grids
supply chains financial networks
telephone networks computer networks
and here we've got a picture for an
example of a physical network
overlaid on top of a map of parts of
north america
these are cities and locations
where they occur on the map and what
we've done is
we had 128 cities in our data set and
distances
between all pairs of cities just so
there's not too many
uh edges we only drew edges very
close together cities so you had to be
closer than 300 miles
to have an edge so there's no long edges
and then we colored the nodes
by their degree so purples have very few
connections or very few cities are
within 300 miles
where this yellow one has many many
cities within 300 miles
on the sides of the nodes are based on
the population so
this is a smaller city but it's very
close to many cities and this is a
large city but it's not very close to
any other cities
and for these kind of maps uh you often
think of things like
what's the shortest distance or shortest
path between two cities or two nodes
um and so uh in addition to that
you often have on these maps
if you're thinking about these physical
systems you're constrained with the
capacity of these edges so
you're interested in maximizing flow
across them based on the capacities
biological phenomena there's again many
many examples so disease spread
right now you're contact tracing a lot
of the news and that's essentially
trying to find these uh
travel these networks where uh
individuals that
are in close proximity to each other
consider having a link
um and that could be that link can be a
possible transmission
vector uh gene expression so this is a
an image over here from a public data
set uh this image as well as the
previous one or on our uh
gallery and i'll talk about the gallery
a bit later in the talk
but if you go to the gallery you can
find these images and you can
find the code and the data as well
and you can play with it and figure out
exactly what's going on but
here what we do is each of the nodes is
a gene and the edges
are associations between genes um
functional associations so genes that
are active in the same
sort of metabolic process or whatever
and we've colored the nodes
and the color is based on community
structure the size of the nodes here
is based on something called betweenness
centrality so
we've already mentioned shortest path
between two nodes so
each of the nodes in this graph each
gene has a shortest path between
two pairs of them and if you
map out all of the shortest paths then
look at each individual node and see how
often it falls on
an average how many of these shortest
paths it falls on
you'll get a sense of it's between a
centrality
um all right so in addition to gene
expressions there's metabolic pathways
you know ant colonies food webs brain
regions
river basins plant pollinator predator
prey and on and on
um social phenomena so here we've got
individuals or
entities within side of government or
business or social clubs or churches
social media schools military and they
may have uh
maybe they work together or they are
direct reports
or um you know maybe they're on the same
team or
they sit close to each other or some
other way
they're related they're friends social
media facebook friends
twitter followers on and on
um so i'm sure everyone at this point uh
has a very clear idea of what kind of
networks we're talking about and you
probably have some sense of networks
that you're
interested in yourself um so just a
summary here from networks from data
the nodes can be many many things
basically some sort of agent or entity
a person animal ancestor city
gene brain regions random variables on
and on
and edges uh there's lots of ways you
can have edges there's some sort of
interaction or friendship or
proximity or some kind of co-occurrence
you show up the same place or
you both things are you know physically
proximate
uh there could be expert knowledge where
you just happen to know the network
structure of something
uh correlation and confidential uh and
i'll say a little bit more about the
correlation one
um you know so for things like brain
regions you might be interested in uh
you know watching uh some person in the
fmri or some sort of a neuro-imaging
scanner and uh that scanner can tell you
each region's activation level over time
uh and you're interested in how these
regions communicate together or
coordinate
uh and so a very simple way of looking
at the graph or network structure there
is to just look at these time series
data for each of these regions
and then again computer correlation
matrix so you know for example these
30 some regions of the brain say
um and then there's a correlation score
for the time series data in each of
these entries
so you know this is brain region five
say and brain region four
and then that's the value and color so
red would be one and
dark blue would be negative one and uh
this corresponds
to a graph where it's fully connected
um and then there's weights on every
edge that correspond to these
correlations
uh we can take that correlation matrix
and we threshold it that's what i did
with this i looked at a histogram
um of these correlations and then
there's an obvious cutoff
i chose that at 0.6 and then everything
above the 0.6 or minus below minus 6
becomes a 1 everything
in between those ranges becomes a 0. and
then
this is the inferred graph so
essentially i've just drawn the graph
here based on
you know for instance two and three
are connected so that's probably there
right there it's two and three
okay so just really to summarize
again uh so some network analysis
problems we've mentioned a few
so shortest path between two nodes a
community structure we saw
in the genomic data you also might be
interested in identifying structures
similar across
networks or analyzing link structure
which we used in determining the
community structure as well
uh all right so say a little bit about
more of the programming aspect of this
data structures and algorithms
uh so first just what kind of data
structures are we gonna work with uh
you know we've mentioned this graph to
begin with and
uh you know we could just put in these
sets but they're not going to be very
convenient so
one of the convenient ways to deal with
it is adjacency matrix
which was very much what we saw in that
threshold graph
um and so here what we've got is uh
there's an edge between one and two so
uh two and one one and two both have a
one there's no edge between three and
five so if we go
three and go down to five we see a zero
or if we go from five and go to three we
see a zero
and should just say so you'll often see
in this in
real graphs as they get bigger and
bigger so as n increases
you'll see more and more zeros in here
so this can be a very inefficient
representation of a graph with all these
zeros of course
there's sparse matrices uh support um to
handle those things as well
but adjacency lists are another way and
they're
often used for a couple reasons one is
uh they immediately don't have the zeros
so
if you have sparse graphs they're
efficient um
the other thing is that many many
algorithms in graph and theory and
network
science have the flavor of uh you know
from a node look at all of its neighbors
so
uh that's exactly what the adjacency
list captures so what we have is
um we represent the graph by looking at
the adjacency structure for all the
nodes so one through five in this case
and uh this is uh all the neighbors of
one
so i mean in the sequence we've got
if you want to explore the neighbors you
would first look at neighbor two then
neighbor three and then number five and
so on
um and i will basically use this
adjacency list
as the underlying representation of uh
graphs in network x
although we won't use this linked list
structure uh we'll talk a bit more in a
second about it
okay so let's just look at a couple of
the algorithms or problems in more
detail so shortest path problem we've
mentioned
and there's many many algorithms to
solve this uh i've just listed a few
here
but uh you know bankster's algorithm uh
they have different flavors so
dijkstra's algorithm
is you know faster than belford belmont
ford algorithm
however bum and ford algorithm handles
uh negative weights where
the dijkstra one doesn't say some of
these are heuristics to speed up some of
these other algorithms
and then these last two are not just
give me a node and i'll tell you the
shortest paths
from that node these give you all pairs
shortest path
and johnson may be faster on sparse
matrices than floyd marshall
for instance applications you know
driving directions using online maps is
the obvious one but
you know also implant facility layout uh
obviously and then sub problems for many
problems like uh
we saw in the between the centrality uh
that was a notion
that you uh want to know about how many
of the shortest paths
in the graph are you on and so to do
that you can need to compute all the
shortest path problems
or all pairs shortest path first
another type of algorithm page rank and
this was the made famous by google
uh where the motivation for them was you
know you do a
web search and uh they find a bunch of
web pages that are useful for your
search query but uh they need to figure
out which one is the most important one
or which one would you most want to see
or
somehow to rank those so that they
presented to you where the most useful
ones are at the top
and the idea was to basically use the
the link structure of the web so the web
itself as a graph where every web page
is a hyperlinked document that points to
other web pages
and the idea of the page rank algorithm
is you want to assign all the web pages
some sort of numerical rank based on how
important they are using the fact that
you believe that important pages
are linked to by many other important
pages um
and uh this has applications in many
areas i
and search was really the sort of it's
celebrity
where it's most celebrated but uh in
this
uh page rank beyond the web review
article
2015 i just took some of the
list of uh things so here there's a
bunch of versions of this
page rank algorithm that are applied to
protein and
genomics so biological data here it's in
citations i can make
citations uh over here we've got some
examples
in uh computer networks um but there's
many many many many more
and if you're interested you can just
read this article
all right so for the second part of the
talk what is network x
so network x is a reference library for
network science algorithms in python
it's key features include it's easy to
use and install
has a flexible data structure broad
range of algorithms supports many many
file formats
a good document has good documentation
simple design
well tested and open source we have a
core developer team of nine individuals
that
support and review and maintain the
software
with contributions from over 430 people
uh it's constantly growing
even now we have many pr's pull requests
on github
from first time contributors i'm hoping
some of you in this audience
listening to me now uh will soon become
first time contributors
and even uh even be greater if
some of you guys would stay along and
become core developers
eventually okay so um
network x is one of the technique
specific libraries in the scientific
python
python ecosystem along with scikit you
know learns like an image stats models
and pandas
uh just in the layer above uh scipy
matplotlib and
numpy and
it's used by many of the application and
domain specific libraries above it you
know astropy biopython and so on
it's like an image also imports networkx
and uses it for a
regency adjacency graph
for image processing uh before i go
further i just want to give you a simple
example
so uh we import network x as nx always
just like
you import numpy as np so here's this
graph and we're going to just manually
create it so first you uh create an
empty graph
and then we're going to add edges so we
add edge a b with weight four
then we add uh edge bd with weight two
and so on
uh at this point we can ask what the
shortest path is
uh in this graph from uh node a to d
and we're gonna ask it uh not just the
shortest path but the shortest weighted
path
by telling it this keyword is weight
and so if it was just the shortest path
either these abd or acd would work but
since we're
interested in the shortest weighted path
uh 4 2 is going to be shorter than 3
plus 4.
so it returns a b and d
our basic data structure for a graph is
a dictionary of dictionary of
dictionaries
so um the very first outer dictionary is
keyed by the nodes of the graph so since
these are keys to a dictionary in python
it's any hashable python object
so if you want to know what the g nodes
are or what your nodes are in type g
nodes
you'll get whatever you put in anything
hashable and the
edges are going to be tuples with
optional edge data
and this is going to be a dictionary
with its neighbors as keys so
that's a very natural syntax if there's
a node u in the graph
then g of u returns a dictionary of used
neighbors
and if v is a neighbor of u then g u v
is going to return the edge attribute
dictionary of the edge u v
we can also ask is nng
to test whether the graph g contains the
node n
and we can also loop over all the nodes
in g just by saying for n and g
the other thing nice about this is very
efficient it's a adjacency list
representation which you already
discussed is nice for sparse graphs that
occur often in natural data
we also finding edges and removing edges
is just two dictionary lookups and
python dictionaries are highly optimized
so
this representation is very efficient
all right to give a little more concrete
look at what this looks like um
that graph g i've just asked network x
to uh
just print it out as addictive dix and
so you can see uh
the other dictionary is keyed by the
nodes a b c and d
and uh node a
has a dictionary associated with it with
b
and c which are its two neighbors and
the value of the a b
is the weight four right so uh
this can get more and more complicated
we haven't have weight and a's and b's
but these can be any hashable objects
and then this can contain
any sort of thing you want basically
okay we provide uh three main graph
types data structures for three main
graph types so simple graphs directed
graphs and then as well as graphs with
parallel edges and
self loops this last one you know so
this is graphs these are digraphs and
this is a multi graphs in our
language in network x and uh for all
these uh graph data structures uh
it's the same sort of dictative dicks so
nodes or any hashable python object
in particular it could be in addition to
being integers or
strings it could be just arbitrary text
it could be images
it could be xml um and then the edges
can have
arbitrary data so you know classically
you'll see things like weight and time
series
things like that capacity
and these graph objects also have some
methods
to view query and modify the graph so we
can
view the nodes and degree and the edges
we can also find out the number of nodes
the number of edges we can query if the
graph is directed
and uh we've already seen we can add
edges to the graph with add edges
we can also modify the graph by adding a
bunch of edges at once from some
container
we can also remove edges and remove
edges from containers as well
and so uh in addition to creating graphs
manually by adding edges we also provide
several graph generators so
there's classic graph like barbell
the complete graph star graph many many
more we provide generators for
um so you typically need to tell these
functions how many nodes you want this
graph on
uh maybe some other parameters you can
look up
we also supplied generators for many
many random graphs uh the classic
eritis reni um as well as uh
graphs that are more uh useful in social
network analysis
uh in addition these random graphs we've
got you know expanders and lattices and
degree sequences and
special social networks and many many
many more
in addition to the data structures and
methods
and generators we have operators so
we can take a graph and can create new
graphs from that graph
and so one way is to take a graph and
get some sub version of it so
you know maybe there's a graph and you
only look at the subgraph on a certain
set of
nodes um we can compose or combine
graphs with cartesian product union
disjoint union and compose
we can also get the complement of graph
so um if
the complement of a graph would be
wherever that graph
has an edge the complement does not have
an edge and wherever it does not have an
edge
the complement does
in addition to manually building the
graphs up or using these other
generators
if we have some data there's many
different file formats we can read those
graphs in
so it's easy to put things in an
adjacency list
or edge list we also support instead of
these plain text files
some of these other formats which are
formats used by other
graph algorithms so we can use these
file formats to transfer data back and
forth forth
uh you know dot is a classic so we'll
talk about graphics again in a second
[Music]
there's gml and graph ml uh basically
these would be things you need to know
about if you uh get one of these file
formats
um and then you can just look it up so i
won't go into too much detail about it
we also provide drawing and
visualization routines so
the primary way we provide graphic
drawing
graph drawing and network drawing is
through matplotlib
so this graph i showed you earlier this
is you know how you go about
drawing it so first you i used a
circular layout just because i wanted it
to
look nice and then i wanted to draw
these edges
weighted so i first needed to figure out
what the widths of these edges would be
i used weights so g edges returns the
tuple of edges um
i'm asking it also including that tuple
the weight
as well so you get a three tuple uh
for each edge so you get the two
vertices as well as the weight
and then we're just going to make a list
of those weights for each of those edges
then we can draw network x by giving it
the graph and
telling it the position and the weights
uh and then i also want to put these
little numbers in so
we need to get the labels um and then
we can use uh the draw network x edge
labels to
label the edges
and if you go to the gallery you can see
many many more examples here just a few
of them
so you can include any since it's
matplotlib you can include
all kinds of other matplotlib graphs and
figures
um and uh if you're interested in
seeing how any of these are made just go
to the gallery and you can get the code
and
play with it yourself we also
support support drawing graphs through
graphis graphis is
probably the biggest classic um example
uh of a graph drawing library and uh it
uses this thing called the dot language
so first we created a is graph um and if
we do a draw we
basically call graphis uh on the dot
under the hood
um to create the png however
it's sometimes useful to get the dot uh
file itself and manually edit it and in
that case you can just write out the dot
file
uh and then this is what that graph g
looks like from graph is
all right so we provide many many
algorithms uh
i'm not going to go through all of these
details this you know this is just a
subset but i was trying to give you some
sense
and thinking that you know maybe some
people in the audience would recognize
some of these uh measures depending on
what kind of problems they're interested
in
uh so we looked at centrality for
example we looked at between a
centrality but we provide many other
centrality measures that are useful
in social network analysis when you're
trying to figure out what the important
nodes in a graph are or network are
clustering a community detection
a link analysis like rank shortest path
et cetera et cetera flows for those
physical networks transportation
networks we were talking about
flow networks um we also support linear
algebra so uh
you know most of these algorithms use
that dictionary addictive dedict
graph uh representation however the
linear algebra stuff we need to
represent them as matrices
so we provide data structure support for
turning your graph into an adjacency
matrix or an incident matrix or a
laplacian matrix which are
very related graph matrix
representations of graphs
um and then once you get in this matrix
form these are all symmetric so you can
compute eigen
values and or
they're squares you can support uh
eigenvalues um
and you know instead of looking at this
i'll just give you this example from the
graph so here this is another gallery
example
it's just the histogram of the spectrum
of a random gnm graph so you
create this gnm graph convert it to a
laplacian matrix and then
look at its eigenvalue decomposition and
then take the eigenvalues
and the eigenvalues will be between zero
and two
for laplacian matrix and uh
one the smallest one will always be zero
uh but the second smallest one which is
also called the algebraic connectivity
may or may not be zero if it is zero
then uh your graph is disconnected if
it's not zero your graph is connected
um and the vector the eigenvector
associated with the second smallest
eigenvector is called the fiddler vector
and that can be used for partitioning
the graph as well as for
embedding the graph in rn spectral
embedding
and you know if you embed your graph in
rn then you can do something like k
means to cluster it uh
so it's often used for some sort of
clustering either through
partitioning it directly or through
embedding
followed by another clustering mechanism
all right so conversion um network x
given its position we basically
provide to and from functions for things
that are level or below so
you can take a graph and convert it to
or from a dictionary or a list
or a numpy array or sci-fi sparse matrix
or a pandas data frame
other graph library is recently igraph
which is not a python
package but provides python bindings for
graph and network analysis
igraph recently added
to and from functionality to support
network x graphs
which is great there's also many of the
application and
domains mainly application specific
libraries um
that support network x to and from
functionality if they have specialized
networks
so there's some of the deep learning
graph uh
libraries um as well as some of i just
give some examples here from
geospatial data analysis uh there's
probably more that i'm not aware of
um so in summary uh complex network
analysis with network x
uh it's flexible it's easy to use and
it's powerful it's flexible um because
the data structure this dedicates allows
arbitrary edge data and node types
um it's also easy to read and convert
too many data formats
uh both file i o as well as uh the
dictionary and
other formats and it's interoperable
with other graph and array libraries
uh it's easy to use so it's a pure
python library so it's inherently
multi-platform
and it's very readable code it's well
documented and well tested
it's powerful so there's hundreds of
functions for creating manipulating
measuring studying and visualizing
networks and it handles data sets with a
100 million
nodes and or 10 million nodes and 100
million edges
that's really the limit of our capacity
um and that requires that you have
some care in your analysis as well as uh
you know sufficiently
beefy hardware um but you know much
smaller networks are
very easily handled by network x if you
get much bigger than
you know 10 million 100 million edges
you'll probably want to get
a different graph analysis library
or come join us and help us develop
faster algorithms and better support
okay so past present and future i just
want to quickly
give you a timeline to give you a sense
of how long these ideas and
libraries been around so in 1998
the creator of python guido first
proposed using a dictionary of list
to represent graphs a few years later
david epstein
approached dictionary of dictionaries
which is what we ended up doing
um eric and peter started an ex at los
alamos in 2002 they were interested
at the time they were doing some
analysis of a disease spread um
so then networks really just started
life as a research project
in 2004 it was publicly announced at the
scipy conference annual conference
and the following year it was released
as open source software after uh you
know going through
whatever the los alamos process was over
the next five years
it you know attracted many many more
developers
continued to be driven largely by
research but uh you know
grad students and uh other young
scientists and faculty
were contributing stuff as well uh based
on their own research
and in 2010 network x 1.0 came out
uh and it continued to develop it needed
to be used and uh
as um it got more and more advanced and
python 3 became more and more useful and
uh
there was some desire to sort of uh do a
major interface redesign
uh to make it much more pythonic three
essentially
and that was a very ambitious project um
and
maybe it was a little bit more than we
bit off more than we can chew at the
time so it was very hard to land 2.0
and at the same time while we were
trying to do that
many of our core developer team
graduated
their phd programs and went into
industry
or joined other projects and so our
developer team
you know shrunk quite a bit after 2.0
however um we did continue uh releasing
regularly with
you know more algorithms improved
algorithms uh
all kinds of bug fixes uh you know
basically a six
every six months we had a release um and
during this beer we've done a lot of
cleanup
uh and we're right now in the midst of
uh
you know trying to do a lot more of this
in the hopes that we can grow in the
future to regrow our
developer team so recently we've added
and improved algorithms
we've improved our testing
infrastructure we switched from nose
which is no longer supported to pi test
we also removed a ton of old legacy code
um
both from supporting uh the pre network
x 1.0 libraries but also from our
supporting python 2 and python 3 at the
same time
we also recently adopted black for style
so
that has really helped us in terms of
reviewing prs because it's a very
unpleasant for both the reviewers and
reviewees if uh
when someone tries to contribute a lot
of code and you're just talking about
you know
what the code style should look like so
now we've got this program that just
runs and uh that's taken that decision
and discussion out of our hands which is
nice
allows us to focus more on the
algorithms and contributions and speed
we've also done a lot of work on the
sort of structure and process so we
have been around since 2002 but we had
never had a logo until now
we just recently joined in on focus
we've also finally
formalized governance and decision
making processes and we acquired
networkx.org just recently
and we've also in preparation for trying
to grow the developer community we've
spent some time trying to
develop and formalize our community
structure so we've adopted a code of
conduct
we've added a mission statement and
values
and we've improved our contributor and
core developer guides created a road map
and enhancement process
proposal process and we recently got a
our first network exit grant through the
chan zuckerberg institute's
essential open source software for
science program
and as a part of that we'll be making a
major release so we have a planned
release schedule of
releasing 2.6 at the end of 2020
early 2021 release nx 3.0
and the goal is that at the nx 3.0 we
have cleaned up a bunch of the
you know our messes and uh we're really
in a position for growth
and so um we're going to be very
aggressive after
network x 3.0 and trying to grow and
recruit new developers
grow our community and recruit
developers and this is part of why we're
talking now to get people excited
and hopefully have some new
contributions
so learning more and getting involved
this is just a screenshot
of our website so if you go to
networkx.org you'll be able to get
a link to our mailing list our issue
tracker our source
you'll also find the release notes and
i'll be able to download the
documentation for the
most recent stable release and if you go
to the latest and hit on doc
it'll take you to this page um and uh
you know i encourage everyone to look at
the tutorial if you're new to network x
also the gallery i hear some of them
you've seen some in the talk already
i you know basically go here click one
of these and it'll take you to another
page where you can get the code
uh and then you can take the code and
run it yourself generate the figures
it's a great way to learn also there's a
reference library with an api
guide for things i also do a lot of
searching here for
functions um oh and then uh if you're
interested in joining us
go to the developer guide and uh the
first thing you'll see is this code of
conduct
so i think that's you know the very
first place to start is read the code of
conduct if you're new to the project
then go to the contributor guide
and then maybe the mission and values um
and then the rest of it you don't need
to worry about right away although
you're welcome to look
um but uh the contributor guy in the
code of contact should basically be
enough to get you uh ready to go and
start working contributing
uh and then how to help uh so again go
to github uh our network
x repository on github and we're looking
at you know lots of things but you know
algorithms and documentation so uh
you know the traveling salesman problem
was recently in the news
uh and we don't have the classic
christopher's algorithm
uh we also have some social network
analysis community detection but we
could use a lot more
uh many of us in the developer community
are interested in biological networks
and we'd love to see better support
um there's also been a lot of work
recently on gras there's
been a lot of discussion of work on
graph isomorphism so i think that this
will probably uh
we'll probably have some new graph
isomorphism algorithms implemented in
the next few months
um documentation so if you don't really
want to contribute to the code but uh
you're interested in doing some more
long-form documentation with
code we would love to have improved
gallery examples so you know
if you have your own uh you know data
set with your own
analysis and examples you might be able
to find a little
nice graphic and share it with others
we'd love to have that
we also are recently adding more of a
notebook binder style tutorial on how-to
documents which we'd love to see things
um you know for example domain-specific
introductions you know network x for
geospatial scientists or network ex for
neuroscientists or neuroimaging people
um as well as education materials so
thank you very much for listening and uh
we are going to have a sprint at this pi
day pi data global i hope to
you join us there and i hope to see you
guys on github as well
thanks a lot